Dan Attias, Director, Producer and Author:Isn't
it true that the record shows that?
Can't you acknowledge that you're going to
wound her again just in the same way you've
heard all these witnesses testify?
The many ways she has been wounded
even though your intentions now are
good. Isn't it inevitable you will?
It's emotional for me recounting that because to
me it got to a level of cracking open a deeper
layer of what happens between human beings. What's
true human behavior? Obviously all human behavior
is true in a certain sense and human beings are
capable and they're doing it but when they're
acting out of defenses, when they're acting
out of self-protection, out of strategizing,
it's a different order of authenticity. What's the
core below? That's what I'm always thirsting for,
that's what it gives me such joy when we
can reach that place in directing anything
and I think there's so many more opportunities
than people may think. My career is basically
directing existing franchises, coming
into stories that are already kind of
structured and shaped and characters are kind of
in place. But I always regard it as an opportunity
okay, but let's look at this the unique
circumstances of this particular episode,
of this particular situation and what would make
me compelled by what's going on. It's not changing
anything necessarily and other than the fact
that it's deepening it's not I don't have to
change characters back situations but I can go
deeper into it which reminds me of another story
which is when I was an actor or studying to be
an actor I arrived at I was an english major
as an undergraduate I got into law school
I didn't know really what I wanted to do
I knew after I got accepted I went through that
all that michigan I realized this is not for me
I'm not going to enroll in that and I didn't know
what I wanted to do and I started I gravitated
towards taking some acting classes because I did
enjoy drama I was an english major I liked story
and I felt it would help free me from some of the
constrictions of these personas we carry around
and these these defenses we erect and the ways in
which I felt not fully present in my life and I
thought well let me act let me let me let me try
playing with imaginary circumstances and I loved
it and I did it for about three years studying
acting I ultimately found that my talents were
I feel are much better suited to direct because I
had a harder time getting out of my own way as an
actor it was kind of hard to have the scrutiny on
me at this moment what am I feeling right now and
a strong critical voice kind of saying oh this
isn't real and and having to overcome all that
what was interesting so I realized as a director
I was better able to get am better able to get
out of my own way and frankly I'm a better actor
when I'm working with direct with actors who are
really talented because I'm not I don't feel
personally on the line and I feel more able to
access that so while I did become a director
as opposed to an actor my experience acting
was probably the most helpful thing I ever
did in in preparing me to direct because I
understood how an actor has to think what would
be helpful for an actor to hear and what would be
destructive what would what would not assist
someone exit to access their deeper resources
but while I was acting I had a few teachers
one was a great teacher named jeff corey
who was a blacklisted actor who then opened
shop in los angeles he taught jack nicholson
among others very talented but over the summer
since I was on the west coast I would take
classes from stella adler who would come in the
summers and offer her workshops and stella was
her most famous pupil is marlon brando she uses
is it was a superstar among among acting teachers
and she left the group theater in the 1930s
because of its emphasis on naturalistic acting
it because of its emphasis on always finding
relating any situation to a particular incident
in your own life it didn't it didn't invite the
imagination as much as she thought people can
our imaginations are treasure chests and we don't
we shouldn't restrict ourselves to always having
to be natural and she she would she would say
to the actors gathered around she would say
being natural is important but it's not everything
and one thing she would do is she she'd stand up
in front of she's a beautiful statuesque very
imposing woman and she'd get up there and
she'd kind of slouch and then she'd pretend
she's smoking a cigarette you and she'd say
is this very good it's natural isn't it she said
that being natural is is just to start and it's
like sometimes actors will use being natural as
an as an excuse for not diving deeper into what
their inner characters in her life is and what
she said and this has been a great lesson for me
as a director is she she was talking to actors
but it applies to all of us as storytellers
she would tell actors as give your characters as
rich and inner life as you possibly can make their
concerns large make their their inner issues big
so so and that goes again to defining story it's
like what is it what is a human being a character
really concerned with it's easy to kind of
find you can justify an action or a dynamic within
a scene in an almost infinite number of ways but
what would be compelling to you what would be
that's a question I'm asking when I read a script
or watch a scene in rehearsal what would make
this compelling to me who would these characters
not just who would these characters have to be
what are the issues what are the issues in their
lives that are active within them what are they
trying to get that isn't just simple as simple as
hitting on a woman and getting a date why I mean
what's they it's like what do they want for their
lives and how does that how does that advance
it in some way yes the dialogue can be the same
I mean an example I said in the book just
came to me was a a mother with a with a with a
young person a young man as a son who's kind
of back at home and just kind of not doing
anything with his life and sleeping in and making
a mess around the house and she's having to pick
up after him all the time well imagine dialogue
between those two characters where the mother
might choose the subtext well the intention I want
him to pick I don't I'm tired of picking up after
him and I want him to lighten my load and pull
your weight around here and he could she could
use that as her subtext and say those lines and
that's natural that's justifiable it makes sense
but how much would we care about her or her son
not not a great deal because that's not a very big
intention if you gave her this the inner life
the intention of something along the lines of
I brought you into this world I think this world
is in trouble I'm concerned about this world
too many people are just looking out for
themselves and we're losing us we're losing all
of our sense of community and helping each other
and it's like if you if you if you don't take
responsibility for yourself if you don't find it a
prior if you don't make it a priority not to make
others clean up after you what kind of person are
you going to be going in the world you may prevent
others from thriving because of your shirking your
own responsibilities and you're better than that
well you wouldn't have to change a border dialogue
but if those were the subtext going on between
the two characters I i would personally be a lot
more interested in both of them and I think the
audience would as well and they would have been
cued to another story that you as the director
had a great had a great power to influence I
wonder if we can just go back to the homeland
yeah courtroom scene so I'm fascinated by this
and and i'd actually like to go and and now I
want to definitely watch this and and dissect it
so I understand that the dialogue was not changed
not bad okay so then you took both actresses
oh yeah let me tell you more yeah please do
it's interesting that I hit upon this new way of
conceiving the scene only the night before we were
supposed to film it and we were already halfway
through filming the entire courtroom sequence
i should say in advance of even getting to the
courtroom sequence because I was concerned of
about keeping maintaining audience interest
in this trial when all that was written was
a bunch of negative witnesses kind of pointing
the finger at Claire Danes and I was concerned
well we have to understand that she still feels
it wants to win we have to make the audience not
assume she's going to lose from the get-go so
how can how can what can I help Claire with in
terms of her performance her intention not simply
because for the writers it's almost as if they
were saying was she's hearing all these things
and she's taking them all in oh I've really been
a bad parent and the reason she can take them in
this was another interesting element of the script
at the beginning of the episode she's just come
out of electroshock therapy because she's had a
bipolar episode that led to manic behavior they
gave her electroshock therapy and now at this
trial she's been essentially dulled in a certain
way she's not she's no longer the driven character
that might be so reactive to people saying
you really didn't do very well that time with
Frannie the name of the daughter and whereas
whereas without the electroshock therapy perhaps
she would get defensive they thought this
was an opportunity where Claire Danes could
carry could be more receptive and hear it
as if so that she'd be hearing this as if
for the first time oh I did do that oh wait
so that was what they thought was the story
was constantly hearing oh yeah I did that oh I
did that oh moy I did that too okay take my child
and I thought that was not very good drama very
good storytelling and and I thought we'd lose
the audience so in advance of finding this new
way for the sister to play the part I had I had
come up with the only thing that I thought could
possibly maintain interest which is that Claire
would be hearing all these things taking
them in but with the conviction that that
no one could possibly love this child any more
than her and that she's now finally hearing it
will ensure that she'll be do a better job as
a parent so that would be a way she could the
audience might understand oh she still wants to
win but there was no dialogue to support that
so I thought all of that would have to be
conveyed by Claire just by the way she was
listening so it was a difficult intention so I
set up a pre-production meeting with Claire Danes
which is not in television it's a rare
thing to do these actors certainly the
leads are generally so skilled and Claire Danes
is one of the consummate actresses in the world
I wanted her to have an idea of what how I
thought she should approach preparing for the part
so we met for coffee during my prep period and I
explained the dilemma which he fully understood
and I said so I think what would be great is as
you're hearing this testimony we want the sense
that it's going in that you're hearing it in a
new way because of this alteration of your brain
but that you're also equally convinced that it's
going to make you a better parent not that you
should give her up so she thought she said okay
i'll do that and so but I wanted to acquaint her
with this way of playing it not just spring it on
her when we show up to film but I knew also that
to support both Claire and the audience
understanding it i'd have to contextualize
what was happening because all she all Claire
would have to convey any of this would be like
looks and facial expressions and no
cross-examination and no I mean I even filmed I
filmed a moment where she leaned over to the
her own lawyer and her lawyer interrupted with a
question that showed she was fighting but I just
filmed it in case they saw my point later but
they didn't want to include that so I had to
figure out ways so if other things in the filming
I did is like well let's give her a notepad and
let's as she's hearing things maybe she's hearing
that and she writes something down as if that's
something she's going to ask earlier but in any
case I prepared Claire for the difficult challenge
she faced still not satisfied that that would be
enough and so the night before the sister's
testimony is when I had this kind of epiphany
how I thought the scene might really work and
again I realized that's not something I can spring
on the actress an actress named Amy Hargreaves
an excellent actress who played Maggie the sister
and she was going to testify the next afternoon
that's when we would film it so I called her up
and I said I've just had this new insight into how
I think the scene would work and i'd like to share
it with you and I shared with her this whole new
approach to her character and it was daunting and
it was asking her to go far deeper into herself
and to make herself vulnerable in a way that
a she probably wasn't even thinking of because
she was in a battle mode she has the adversary
in this courtroom she was going to go in and kind
of kick ass and take names or whatever they say
and so I say no that's not what this is gonna
be about it's gonna be about you facing your
own sense of deficiency publicly and she loved it
because it gave me she was concerned because she'd
have to do some of that work that night but as any
good actor does they they relish an opportunity to
go deeper that's why they I think the best actors
are in it and that's why I'm in it that's why it's
like we want to crack open something deeper within
ourselves and get to experience it because life
has its own complications there's a lot of things
you need to keep defenses in place for but in
in the imagine the world of the imagination and
plays and drama it goes to your question about
why we go see stories why we want to see him we
get to see things happen that don't happen so
easily in life and so so she did the preparation
and she came in the next day and was brilliant
and I should say that for anybody who looks at the
episode I don't know how much of this would really
land I think people will feel oh yeah that made
sense what happened but what's also interesting to
me is about this story is I realize that there's
a large section of the fan base of homeland who
really would regard this as kind of not one of
their highlight episodes because it doesn't deal
with international intrigue or mortal peril or
all these exciting things it's simply a sense of
domestic drama but to me it was one of and I've
done some episodes that fit that bill I did one
on the fourth season called 13 hours in Islamabad
[TV Show Homeland] which was the overtaking of the
American Embassy in Pakistan and it was one of the
most exciting shows I think of the whole series
that gets a lot of attention this was just a
little custody trial but I get so much pleasure
knowing that the work that went in and
the depth that we were able to reach
and making a moment real and that's what I think
is the director's job and all and all of us
together but the director is the final arbiter
is the director is the one who's in charge of
assessing moment to moment how the story is
being told and when it's at its best form
and so I take a lot of inner satisfaction
from that particular sequence.
What makes you care about a character?